I'd like to tell you a story to the
people that you don't the you remember
but we were in Columbus okay you
remember we used to do a tour bus thing
mm-hmm
so there was a school limo outside the
comedy club yeah that they were I don't
know they were gonna take us to a strip
club or something
okay and I I was in the limo with two
girls and they were I she's masturbating
and she lets you bring other babes home
yeah and then yeah I thought you were on
stage no but then the what happened was
you walk in the limo you go what about
me did and you grab the girls and you
brought them to the [ __ ] your tour
bus well I was in the limo so now I had
to chase you down go into the [ __ ]
tour bus and we were back there and then
these two girls started blowing me and
stuff and you taped me right video tape
yeah you start taping me and I've been
asking for that tape all these years you
won't give it back
bang bang bang Bros calm you don't still
have that video - I probably have it
yeah I remember there and then then
warlock had got some from warlock was
there remember
yeah we're like was the road manager
yeah like one of the chimp coordinators
towards the end yeah yeah yeah and he
looked like a warlock haunting name yeah
oh he had like he was like he's very
like mythical okay yeah I met him I met
him because my first world manager this
guy Nick light and Nick light was a gem
meeting that no Nick's the best he was
uh he was my road manager cuz I met him
I think through Rico suave that wasn't
the punch line Rico suave was like the
first big artist on Interscope Records
he was [ __ ] huge yeah like the biggest
on MTV ever like kinda like MC Hammer
but for the Latinos yeah yeah right and
and you know Nick was was Rico suave my
manager and I think my manager Michael
rothenburg was like friend I don't know
what it was but somehow Nick became my
road manager and and then warlock used
to be Nick's like I guess guitar tech or
some [ __ ] for Rico suave and then they
they came out with me yeah yeah that's
how those dates though those dates that
did we
the event I remember one time we did a
tour where you did guard from all their
no I know it's changed my life when Sam
Kinison used to bring you up on the road
you did the same tour and you brought me
and then remember at their very end we
went to Sam kinnison's graveyard yeah I
have all that video yeah and we were
really I mean it was a very solemn
moment and because uh because I I mean I
grew up watching him you know so I
thought was an honor kind of in a weird
way it was heavy yeah I feel that I feel
that way when I bring all the guys out
you know yeah sandy danto and I'm going
out Benji Benji
I just AM like next month and I don't
know I bring all the guys with me you
know I like I love paying it forward
it's like the best thing yeah and I love
training you guys out on the road my god
because like you know like you can work
the store for so long but you got to get
on the road from those packed crowds
yeah white people and like the white
crowd yeah crazy [ __ ] yeah America
you know Michael we were Trump
supporters those are my fans yes the
people that are pushing down the statues
yeah yeah yeah I mean we would be in the
stick sometimes huh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
it was crazy dude yeah but [ __ ] crazy
did you ever hear the story about what
was his [ __ ] name John the guy that
jumped off the bus Wow what was his
[ __ ] name John [ __ ] I was with Simone
on the road and we were [ __ ] uh John
[ __ ] Simone will tell you but we were on
the bus and we're touring and we're
[ __ ] in the middle of like Macon
Georgia and we're on this bus and the
[ __ ] dude he's an open or junk he
worked [ __ ] in San Diego the bald guy
John John got sick God's sake Johnny the
Gothic acid yeah you heard the story oh
yeah the story was this okay so John and
the gods like a nice [ __ ] gnarly yeah
we started together Jonathan then nicest
guy in the world right and funnier than
very funny very funny guy he's under the
business it's so sad but my point is
that he went on opening for Pauly and
then someone slipped him acid I don't
know what happened we were in Macon
Georgia we're at the after-party at a
bar
yeah I had to wake up and do press and
in Atlanta so you're on a box he told
him to stop the bus no we were watching
like [ __ ] Sam Kinison documentaries
or Lenny Bruce things or like you know
or watch DeNiro and you know where he
played a comedian yeah remember that
yeah I forgot that oh yeah that's called
the King of Comedy
King of Comedy feeling all the comedy
stuff yeah and Austin he freaked out he
jumped off the bus he ran into the woods
right ran into the woods went fast
it wasn't like going slow was going
crash he [ __ ] jumps in the [ __ ]
woods and he just takes off yeah and me
and Simone we go we chase them yeah I
only mean I'm with Tyrell remember to
relman yeah yeah yeah the big guy yeah
and then we [ __ ] I'm like dude get on
the [ __ ] bus do it I got [ __ ]
press in the morning you [ __ ] weirdo
yeah he's like oh you guys are trying to
rape me and you guys are trying to you
know name me yeah you guys are trying to
do some [ __ ] to me you know that stuff
and I might do just get on the [ __ ]
bus yeah I mean stop being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's go yeah I mean like I left
him like if anyone should jump off the
bus I should jump off the that's the
thing that was so [ __ ] up about me
it's like I would go on tour and
everyone around me was more [ __ ] up
than me yeah yeah I know one that's
supposed to be [ __ ] up yeah yeah I
know right but do you think that you
have something to do with us us being
[ __ ] up so we we get them back on the
bus yeah and I swear to God do we keep
going yeah any [ __ ] jumps off again I
know I heard that yes off again yeah you
know and the bus yeah I know about it
because I swear to God Jeff Richards and
I we're at the Taco Bell on Law &
Western on Western on Sunset around the
area and we had heard from Simone that
John is gone and he's in a hotel room
hotel room yeah my bus driver says I'm
not driving him anymore yeah like this
is illegal and I'm gonna get in trouble
right the bus driver says I'm pulling
off to the next hotel so we just dropped
him off at the hotel and I said dude you
can't be on the bus anymore you're like
a hazard yeah legal
why so then we heard that he had
barricaded the hotel room door with this
mattress yeah and he thought that people
were coming to get him like paranoid
schizophrenic but he's I know the guy
how old is he
he was a couple years older than me but
he is the nicest guy he's a sweetheart
used to be a teacher for the retards in
San Diego yeah but maybe it was like
creeping in ya know he normal now yeah
oh and he was fed acid it was for PC
Pearson or something that's what I heard
yeah
okay so then he ended up in a hotel room
and then he was on the tour anymore
right yeah his brother picked him up oh
my god how says brother yeah be like
little Stevie coming to get a little
baby Bobby Michigan or something and you
go we're sharing the same bed hotel room
that wasn't cool I'm still mad at you
for that no cuz basically when you're on
the road you're on the bus and then you
and then you pull over and you everyone
goes to the hotel room that's just you
know check-in yeah Jackie bababa and I
was like I don't I said was lonely but I
didn't I'm always going to my hotel room
by myself and it was Detroit was [ __ ]
creepy and our hotels next to a [ __ ]
a like a graves gravesite because we're
playing a chaplains which is on the
outside yeah Joplin's yeah just like
this combi club connected to a bowling
alleys [ __ ] gnarly dude like really
nor the wind checks bounced from there
all and after you know we get a thing
Austin I knock on Bobby's door and he's
like looks and he's like what do you
want and I'm like dude I want to stay
with you you know let me stay in your
room with you and you're like no no no
no I don't want it and I'm like I'm like
no for real I want to stay in he's like
you're kidding right he goes you got
your own sweet dude and I'm like I know
but I want to stay next to you I go and
I looked in his room he's got two beds
yeah he doesn't I'm like let me just
stay in the extra bed let me just take
the bet any you know and literally I'm
like dude he goes you're [ __ ] serious
I go yeah I'm serious I wanna be next to
you and we can watch TV and just chill
and talk as a friend you know me so I'm
Jimmy my way in the room i Jimmy my way
in the room and he literally curls on
the floor instead
crying like he starts crying for real
for real cuz he really like it's
devastating yeah cuz that would mean
that I'm not gonna get any sleep okay
cuz I'm I now I had to see what he's
gonna do one Chinese eye is open right
[Laughter]
and I literally started crying and then
he got mad he was like I'm gonna go to
my room he went back to his room yeah
yeah a really terrible sleep oh that's
my fault
you you don't mean you make money you
should have your own room it's weird
no I can teach it yeah I just wanted to
hang with my friend you don't know what
he's like he scratches my skin but not
in a friendly way like that doesn't get
into the skin with his claws see that's
the thing is that our relationship
hasn't changed
no it's got more fun [ __ ] up a complex
[Music]